okay let's talk about the basic
differences between ionic and covalent
bonds two different ways in which atoms
can connect to one another well let's
first look at the basic parts to an atom
here is a square from the periodic table
B E is the element beryllium and
elements are made from atoms and atoms
have three basic parts first of all
there are the protons these are the
parts that have a positive charge from
the periodic table square I know that
from looking at the atomic number
beryllium has one two three four protons
another part of an atom is what is
called what are called electrons these
are parts that have a negative charge
usually the amount of protons is the
same as the amount of electron so I now
know that beryllium has one two three
four electrons and then the third part
to an atom are called the neutrons now
be careful the number 9 and the square
that's not the number of neutrons the 9
is when you add up the combined amount
of protons and neutrons in in beryllium
zigzagoon - Trent's will equal 9 so we
just got done saying there's four
protons plus how many neutrons will give
us nine simple math there is going to be
a total of five neutrons so how are
these parts arranged well atoms have a
nucleus and in the nucleus are the
protons and the neutrons surrounding the
nucleus are these levels of electrons
now the levels of electrons you might
know can only hold a certain amount the
first level the inside level can carry
two electrons to makes it full or stable
the second level can carry eight
electrons eight electrons will make the
second level full or stable and even
though beryllium doesn't have a third
level many atoms do and if an atom has a
third level eight electrons will make it
full or stable so let me put two
electrons in the first level of
beryllium and the electrons kind of
orbit the nucleus and so now that first
level is filled it's what we call stable
well the other two electrons have to go
in the second level
and here's the problem with beryllium
it's unstable it's unstable because the
second level is not filled the second
level can carry eight electrons but
there's only two that makes it unstable
so why do atoms bond with one another
well they bond with one another to
become stable and what that means is
that they are trying to obtain more
electrons so they can fill their levels
now there are two basic types of bonds
and that's why you're watching this
videos to learn the difference between
the covalent bonds and the ionic bonds
let's go over covalent bonds first okay
so the basic definition of a covalent
bond it's a bond between atoms where
they share electrons and so the goal of
the of atoms forming covalent bonds is
to become stable to fill their levels of
electrons and the classic example of
this is oxygen Li the oxygen that we
breathe
o - the oxygen that plants make by doing
photosynthesis is actually two atoms of
oxygen stuck together so let's look at
oxygen from the periodic table it's got
eight protons it's got eight neutrons
so let me draw oxygen number one I'll
get two oxygens electrons in a moment so
in the nucleus of oxygen number one are
going to be eight protons and eight
neutrons well I'm also going to draw the
electron levels around the nucleus and
now I can tell you that oxygen has eight
total electrons so when I draw the
electrons I'll put two electrons in
level number one because that's all
level number one can carry and then I'll
put the leftover six electrons in level
number two in the end notice how the
first level the inside level is stable
because it can only hold two and it has
two but the second level is unstable it
can carry eight electrons but it only
has six that's a problem it's unstable
well the oxygen that we breathe is
actually made from two atoms so we have
to draw a second oxygen atom like the
first it has eight protons it has eight
neutrons in the nucleus it will have a
couple levels for the electrons
and it's got eight total electrons so
just like before I'll put two electrons
in level number one I'll put the
remaining six electrons in level number
two so the first level is stable it's
filled the third level is unstable it's
not filled it doesn't have eight
electrons it only has six so what's
going to happen when these two atoms are
both unstable well in this case they're
going to form a covalent bond they're
going to overlap their electron levels
and share their electrons so when you
count up the electrons of oxygen number
one one to level number one is stable
how about level number two level number
two has one two three a shared fourth a
shared fifth six seven eight level
number two was once unstable but it is
now stable because of the sharing of
electrons let's look at oxygen number
two oxygen number two has one two
electrons in the first level first level
stable look at the outside level one two
three four a shared fifth six seven a
shared eighth because they're sharing
electrons oxygen number twos outside
level is now stable so if I set those
electrons in motion you know those
shared electrons are zigzagging back and
forth kind of like in a figure eight
right here and because of this sharing
of electrons both oxygens oxygen number
one oxygen number two they have filled
outside levels that's a covalent bond
let's look at an ionic bond next so the
definition of an ionic bond it's a bond
where one atom gains an electron and
another looses remember atoms make bonds
in order to become stable they're trying
to fill their levels of electrons a
classic example is sodium chloride na is
sodium CL is chlorine you put the two
together you have what's also called
salt well here's the square
for sodium from the periodic table the
eleven is the amount of protons that's
the atomic number
I know sodium has 11 protons so there
they are if you remember from earlier
the protons and the electrons are
usually found in the same amount so I
now know sodium also has 11 electrons
the 23 on the bottom is the mass the
combined protons plus neutrons for
sodium adds up to 23 so we just said 11
protons plus what mystery number equals
23 simple math sodium has 12 neutrons
all right let's put this together now so
let's put this atom of sodium together
the protons and neutrons are clumped in
the nucleus I'm going to add one two
three levels for the electrons you'll
see why I added three in a moment level
number one can only carry two electrons
hey at least it's stable it's filled
level number two can hold eight
electrons so I'll put eight of them in
level number two level number three can
carry eight but there's only one left
over so when we look at the levels level
number one is stable level number two is
stable level three is unstable level
three can carry eight electrons but
there's only one that makes it unstable
all right I want to put that note in the
upper left-hand corner to remind me that
sodium has 11 protons 11 electrons
it also has 12 neutrons but because
neutrons have no charge we don't need to
focus on them I want to shift focus away
from sodium to now I want to shift our
focus to chlorine from the periodic
table the 17 is the atomic number or the
amount of protons if you remember the
proton number is pretty much always
going to be the same number of electrons
so I now know chlorine has 17 electrons
the mass is 35
that's 17 protons plus what number
equals 35
that means chlorine has 18 neutrons so
now I want to draw the chlorine atom it
has 17 protons it also has 18
in the nucleus so now when I draw the
electron levels one two three levels for
the electrons I got to draw 17 electrons
I can only put two electrons in level
number one it's filled it's stable that
means there's 15 electrons I have to
account for I cannot put all 15 or level
number two but I can put eight and level
number two that will leave me a total of
seven to account for I can put all seven
in level number three I hope you see the
problem though level number three is not
filled it's not stable so look at level
number one for chlorine it's stable
because it's filled with two electrons
look at level number two it's stable
because it's filled with eight electrons
the problem lies with level number three
it's unstable it's not filled there's
only seven electrons in level three
eight will make it stable so just like
last time with sodium I want to put a
reminder in the upper right-hand corner
for chlorine chlorine has 17 protons 17
electrons I want to see that to remind
me as we go through the next part look
at my definition an ionic bond is where
one atom gains an electron but another
loses
watch what chlorine does is three to one
chlorine is stealing an electron from
sodium that's going to completely change
the amount of electrons that each has
sodium used to have 11 electrons but it
just lost one it only has 10 chlorine
used to have 17 electrons but it just
stole one it just gained one it now has
18 well let's look at the levels of
electrons to see if they're stable
sodium on the left two in the first it's
stable eight in the second its stable it
doesn't even have a third level anymore
that's okay look at chlorine on the
right two electrons in the first level
it's stable eight electrons in level two
it's stable chlorine used to have an
unstable level three but it just took an
electron from sodium it now has the
desired amount of eight in level three
it too is
Abell but how do these things actually
stick together
watch this sodium on the left is
actually like a positively charged
magnet now it has 11 protons protons
have a positive charge and only 10
electrons electrons have a negative
charge so because it has more protons
it's positively charged chlorine it's
just the opposite
chlorine now has more negatively charged
electrons that gives it a negative
charge what happens when you put a
positive and a negative magnet together
they stick they bond with one another
the positive charge of sodium is
attracted to the negative charge of
chlorine like two oppositely charged
magnets magnetism draws them together
and that's what holds them together in
an ionic bond sodium is a positive
magnet chlorine is a negative magnet
they bind together ionic Li so there you
have it the basic differences and
similarities between covalent bonds and
ionic bonds go ahead and pause the video
if you want to compare and contrast the
two I hope you found the video really
helpful you know leave your thoughts
below in the comment box I look forward
to reading them take care best wishes to
you